2019's Joker takes a daring new approach
to Batman's most famous adversary as
inspired by gritty 70s Cinema as it is
by comic books Joaquin Phoenix plays
Arthur Fleck a troubled wannabe comedian
who suffers an emotional breakdown on
the way to becoming the clownish super
villain Joker earned more than one
billion dollars at the box office and
Phoenix took home the best actor Oscar
for his work in the film clearly there's
demand for additional movies about this
Joker's rise to infamy in June 2022 Todd
Phillips confirmed rumors of a sequel
when he posted a photo of the next Joker
script to Instagram the snapshot
revealed that the film will be titled
Joker felia de as it turns out Phoenix
will return in the title role alongside
Lady Gaga as Harley Quinn and in a
fascinating twist the new film will be a
musical set in Arkham Asylum the film
will dance its way into theaters on
October 4th 2024.